notre patrimoine immobilier quand il
n'est pas simplement détruit par les
bulldozers et maintenu à bout de bras
par des passionnés qui mettent beaucoup
d'énergie mais comme vous allez le voir
les belles vieilles maisons n'entre pas
dans les petites cases des assureurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la maison était construite pour le frère
du Seigneur c'est 3620
ici c'est l'ancienne route qui me
portait de Québec à Montréal et c'est
pour ça que la maison est devenue un
relais de poste là où il faisait les
changements de chevaux
André Tanguay a acheté cette maison
située sur le chemin du roi Donnacona
dans le vieux village les écureuils il y
a une quarantaine d'années j'avais un
goût absolument
particulier pour les maisons anciennes
pour cette maison c'est tout
il est maintenant en Dieu une nouvelle
étape de sa vie et il tente de vendre sa
maison qui a été inscrite en 2013 dans
le répertoire du patrimoine bâti de la
MRC de Portneuf
et j'ai d'autres projets et j'ai besoin
de
liquidités il a reçu plusieurs visites
depuis qu'il a mis sa maison en vente à
l'été 2021 c'est ça la particularité de
cette maison là c'est que tout a été
refait
180 j'ai un couple qui me qui voulait me
faire une offre d'achat et ils sont
informés pour assurer la maison et ont
trouvé aucune compagnie qui voulait les
assurer
Dieu au fait que la maison avait le
titre de patrimonial et ça s'est bloqué
la vente
monsieur tanguet a même voulu aider le
couple en proposant ses propres
assureurs de les couvrir il doit
intéresser moi ça me dérange pas que je
sois là depuis parce que je suis un
client de longue date
[Musique]
c'est une maison qui qu'on appelle une
maison école et il y a eu 175 élèves
cette maison là ta porte de gauche la
porte de droite et les probablement les
entrées pour les classes des garçons et
des filles
André Lemieux et lui aussi un amoureux
des maisons anciennes il a acheté cette
maison située à Limoilou en plein cœur
de Québec dans les années 80 elle fait
partie des 350 maisons patrimoniales
classées par le ministère de la Culture
et des Communications du Québec il veut
maintenant la vendre on est dans un
quartier central qui est en demande avec
des services de proximité on a eu
beaucoup de visites beaucoup de visites
parce que c'est une maison qui est qui
avait beaucoup d'intérêt
en décembre 2021 la vente de sa maison
est conclue il a accepté l'offre d'un
acheteur c'est quelqu'un qui était déjà
conscientisé par l'architecture qui
avait fait déjà de la restauration de
maison anciennes dans son patelin et qui
avait beaucoup d'intérêts pour la maison
beaucoup
mais la vente de la maison est
finalement bloquée à cause des
assurances tout allait bien même m'en
donner ça s'est malade
tant aux acheteurs de négocier le prêt
hypothécaire mais le prêteur exige
d'avoir des assurances et là ça bug les
assurances tous sauf peut-être une qui
chargeait un attache-tard qui s'est
désisté entre 4006 et 12000 par année
avec une protection partielle
Claude Michaud gère le dossier des
assurances à l'association des Amis et
propriétaires de maisons anciennes du
Québec lapmac cet organisme reçoit
chaque année une centaine d'appels de
membres qui ont des problèmes à assurer
leur propriété le travail d'un assureur
c'est quoi dévaluer le risque que
représente cette propriété-là et de
proposer une prime qui qui est en
corrélation avec le risque qui est
encouru est-ce qu'il pose des questions
sur la la tuyauterie sur la plomberie
sur l'électricité on a l'impression que
ce travail là en amont ne se fait pas
je pense qu'il y a de la méconnaissance
de ce qu'est un bâtiment ancien et de ce
qu'est la restauration de bâtiment 5
Gérard Beaudet enseigne à l'Université
de Montréal à la Faculté de
l'aménagement il est bien au fait de la
frilosité des assureurs envers les
maisons anciennes en base l'analyse du
risque sur les situations des pays un
bâtiment tout à fait exceptionnel qui
est massivement détruit par le sinistre
et qu'on va être obligé de reconstruire
selon les techniques traditionnelles de
l'époque alors que on sait pertinemment
que ces cas-là sont quand même plutôt
rares sont quand même plutôt rarissime
je trouve ça un injustice total pour les
propriétaires de ces maisons on devrait
plutôt les assister et les aider faire
en sorte que quand ils vend la maison
que quelqu'un dise bon on peut assurer
la maison selon le Bureau d'assurance du
Canada la difficulté d'assurer des
maisons anciennes n'est pas un problème
généralisé mais ça porte parole d'une
Crevier reconnaît quand même une
certaine réticence chez les assureurs à
l'égard des maisons anciennes les
assureurs quand vous vendent une police
le service schizophrent un service de
règlement de sinistre qui veut dire
qu'il faut qu'il soit capable de réparer
les dommages de reconstruire la maison
et s'ils ont un doute important qui va
être capable de rendre un service
adéquat ils vont parfois préférer ne pas
offrir l'assurance ça demande quand même
des connaissances assez pointues quand
on parle de maison classée de maison
citée
[Musique]
des refus des augmentations qui ont pas
de bon sens faut y travailler maintenant
pour que dans à court terme à moyen
terme ont pu se jouer d'une couverture
d'assurance normale c'est contradictoire
tout ça parce que le ministère est
classe les biens les maisons etc mais on
n'est pas protégé par les assureurs et
ils reviennent à mon sens de la culture
du mois c'est comme ça la culture que
vient la responsabilité de monter un
dossier de documenter le problème la
protection du patrimoine relève
effectivement du ministère de la Culture
et des Communications Gérard Bodin pense
que la solution se trouve dans une
combinaison d'assurance privée et
publique que les assureurs couvrent
l'ordinaire de la protection d'un
bâtiment en cas de sinistre mais que la
valeur patrimoniale elle soit soumis
justement par un organisme public un peu
comme on le fait dans le monde agricole
où on a une assurance publique
collective on pourrait avoir la même
chose c'est à dire qu'une part du risque
pourrait être ass par l'État contenu
effectivement que ce qu'on impose aux
propriétaires c'est au nom du bien
commun des dizaines de MRC de
municipalités demandent aux nouveaux
ministres de la Culture et des
Communications Mathieu Lacombe d'agir
nous sommes allés leur rencontrer son
dossier que juge important parce que ça
touche notre patrimoine en même temps
c'est complexe parce que ça relève de
l'entreprise privée donc on est en train
de regarder c'est quoi les options qui
sont à notre disposition que déjà des
discussions avec le Bureau d'assurance
du Canada les discussions que j'aimerais
voir peut-être un petit peu plus
intensifié et c'est entre autres
là-dessus qu'on va travailler au cours
des prochains mois certains proposent
des initiatives intéressantes comme par
exemple la création d'une entreprise
l'équivalent de l'assurance école est-ce
que vous avez de l'argent de quelque
chose comme ça je vais rester très
prudent pour l'instant parce que je suis
en train de m'approprier ce dossier là
c'est vraiment une réelle menace parce
que finalement si on abandonne les
maisons mais c'est autant de ma maison
qui qui sont qui seront détruites et
qu'ils ne feront pas partie de notre de
notre environnement
dans les prochaines années ils vont
éliminer des assurances à peu près tout
le patrimoine du Québec
si on continue comme ça il faut qu'il y
ait une solution avec pas tant que
gouvernement bougera pas ça va être
difficile pour tout le monde
autant pour les acheteurs que pour les
vendeurs
et pourtant le problème ne date pas
d'hier nous vous avons présenté un
reportage en tout point semblable en
2012 et en 2020 la vérificatrice
générale du Québec a reproché au
ministère de la Culture de ne pas
assumer ses responsabilités pour
protéger le patrimoine immobilier